Nice!
.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
1. Versuch!
2. Versuch!
3. Versuch!
4. Versuch!
7. Versuch!
8. Versuch!
9. Versuch!
Also Leute ich bin schon da, ich muss doch ran aber schnell was fordern.
Also Leute wir machen jetzt das gleiche was wir letztes mal auch gemacht haben, dass wir
heute wach werden und uns keine Reef Bildchen angucken.
Das soll übrigens richtig schlecht sein, das habe ich jetzt schon an ein paar Stellen
gelesen.
Aber es ist echt schlecht, es ist echt schlecht, es ist echt schlecht.
Wobei das ist 34 Minuten, das ist ganz schön lang, das kann man das nicht angucken komplett.
Ich finde auch die zwei Heldin irgendwie für Wolfenstein voll nicht passend.
Weißt du du hattest in Wolfenstein hattest du immer so den übertriebenen vor Kraft platzenden
Held am Start und jetzt hast du zwei Mädels die quasi genauso easy wie irgendwelche Nazis
waren, irgendwie fasst das nicht.
Ich glaube Solo ist das Game noch schlechter, die Lautstärke eigentlich okay.
Aber New Colossus ist echt unerfolgreich, das Ding hat überall super Bewertungen gekriegt,
ich habe das auf jedem Let's Play Channel gesehen, ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen,
dass sich das so schlecht verkauft hat.
Ich habe davon abgesehen, dass das Youngblood wohl richtig scheiße ist.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass neues Bethesda Game rauskommt und es verbuckt ist, da war ja gar
keiner drauf gekommen oder?
Guckt euch mal den Arm an, hat er einfach nur einen riesen Foff oder ist der Arm irgendwie
ein bisschen unrealistisch gequetscht lang?
Stimmt, da schreiben aber viele Coop Games und die sucken dann, es gibt ja nicht so viele
Coop Games.
Also richtige Coop Games fallen mir jetzt nicht allzu viele ein, außer was haben wir
da?
Was gibt es denn sonst auch so für rein rassische Coop Games?
Gibt es nicht so viele.
Das sieht vollkommen hängen geblieben aus, was haben die sich denn dabei gedacht?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist das für ein Helm?
Was soll denn das sein, das sieht aus wie der Kopf, der in der Playstation 3 gefangen
ist.
Das sieht aus wie eine Playstation 3, wo der Kopf eingequetscht ist dazwischen.
Was soll denn das sein?
Der Typ kommt mir von der Stimme übelst bekannt vor.
Wer ist das denn?
Nee.
Moment, sieht man den irgendwo?
Der kommt mir übelst bekannt vor von der Stimme her.
Der hört sich an wie jemand, der Videos über 3D Drucker macht, aber das ist er nicht.
Hört euch mal.
Der Typ hört sich genauso an wie der 3D Drucker Typ.
Bloß halte das Mikrofon nicht dran, das hört sich übelst ähnlich an.
Das sieht aus wie der Kopf, der in der Playstation 3 gefangen ist.
Das verdammte Armour-versus-Ammo-System, das verdammte Checkpoint-System, das Fakt, dass ich das Spiel nicht pausieren kann,
auch wenn ich solo spiele und natürlich auch die Mikrotransaktionen.
Keine dieser Dinge hat mit Koop-versus-Solo nichts zu tun.
Sie stehen auf ihren eigenen zwei Füßen, so langweilig wie möglich, egal wie man das Spiel spielt.
When I reviewed Rage 2, I was like, listen, this is pretty fun, it just hasn't got a lot of variety in it, it lacks a bit of personality, but it's fine.
Rage 2 wasn't a great game, but it wasn't a terrible game either.
It was just so mindless fun for a while and then you moved on.
It was clearly trying to recapture the core of what made the first Rage enjoyable to some people,
while also taking it to some new directions to, you know, capture a new world.
Rostein Youngblood feels like what you'd make if you were trying to piss off and alienate your existing fanbase.
It asks, what would Wolfenstein fans hate?
And then it does that exact thing.
And perhaps the perfect place to start when talking about all of this is the writing.
Alright, let's watch a quick scene from the new Colossus.
Ja gut, das kennen wir.
Was ist hier, woran diese komische Bildspar reingeht?
Okay, so people had problems with the new Colossus as a video game,
but most people were pretty sold on the writing and the presentation.
People felt that there was perhaps too much of it,
but when those scenes were rolling, they were riveting. Great characters, great dialogue, great sense of tension, great stuff.
Now, let's take a look at your average scene from Wolfenstein Youngbloods.
Was ist das? Oh, ist das schlecht? Oh, ist das schlecht? Oh, meine Fresse, ist das? Oh, ist das schlimm? Oh, ist das schlimm?
Ach, du Scheiße.
The fuck? Was zum Teufel? Geh jetzt ab.
Oh, war die Zwischensequenz davor peinlich. Eine Güte, wenn die alle so sind, dann ist es besser, dass ich das auf keinen Fall selbst im Sale nicht hole.
Oh, ist das peinlich, die Zwischensequenzen.
Was zum Teufel? Was? Was? Was ist das für ein Quatsch?
Oh, das ist so peinlich. Das tut so weh, man zuhört schon.
Oh, das tut so weh. Das tut so weh, man zuhört schon.
Und warum machen die so komische Emotes? Oh, das tut echt weh. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wenn man da jetzt was dagegen sagt, kommen die Feministen gleich wieder an und sagen, oh Max, da kannst du nichts dagegen sagen. Du findest das nur scheiße, weil das zwei Mädels sind in der Hauptrolle. Hätten sie da zwei Typen, wird es überhaupt nichts dazu sagen.
Also wenn das das Highlight ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ja, da hat er recht. Das ist vollkommen egal, wer das ist. Das ist einfach schlecht geschrieben.
Was? Ich finde, das sieht null aus wie 1980. War Sushi 1980 tatsächlich schon ein Ding? 1980 hat auch kein Mensch Sushi gefuttert.
1980 wussten die meisten Leute nicht mehr, dass es Sushi überhaupt gibt.
Es sieht auch null aus 1980. Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie aus dem ersten Homefront plus mit Metallkisten.
Das ist ein Computerraum. Das sieht aus wie das 80s aus. Und außer von den ersten Songs, die auf Boomboxen gespielt haben, gibt es fast keine Musik in diesem Spiel. Wenn du ein 1980s Motiv machen willst, dann wird die Musik wahrscheinlich ein fairer Teil davon tragen müssen. Und das hört man überhaupt nicht.
Ich glaube, die Entwickler haben sich an Blutdragen und seltsamere Dinge angeschaut und dachten, ja, dann machen wir das. Das wäre cool. Aber dann haben sie realisiert, dass sie neue Kunststoffe und neue Musik für diese Vision haben müssen.
Und so haben sie das schnell aufgenommen und versucht, die Schreibung so über den Top-Tubular zu machen, dass wir es nicht helfen konnten.
Ich glaube, es ist ein guter Punkt, dass die Entwickler so schnell aufgenommen haben, dass sie neue Kunststoffe und neue Musik für diese Vision haben müssen.
Und so haben sie das schnell aufgenommen, dass sie neue Kunststoffe und neue Musik für diese Vision haben müssen.
Und so haben sie neue Kunststoffe und neue Musik für diese Vision haben müssen.
Ist das Ingame-Währung? Oder ist das Echtgeld-Währung?
Ist das Echtgeld-Währung? Oder ist das Echtgeld-Währung?
Ist das Echtgeld-Währung?